[Musique]
on essaie juste d'avoir les petits bouts
du puzzle quels souvenirs as tu de ce
qui s'est passé
j'aime bien celui là regarde le plan où
étais tu quand ça s'est produit
je me rappelle quand tu as repris
connaissance
tu as vu des gens oui
qu'est ce qu'il faisait elle était mort
parce ressemble terriblement théo avec
ce qu'on a vécu tous les deux
plus vite nous retrouvons nos activités
habituelles mieux c'est
[Musique]
aux portes et plat creux c'est comme
s'il m'avait envoyé exactement là où je
devais être et auprès de qui j'avais
besoin d'être
[Musique]
ta mère est morte
oui
j'ai la certitude que vous y étiez et je
sais ce qui se trouvait dans cette salle
également
[Musique]
à
le chardonneret
avant et après tout et avant et après
entre les deux il ya le tableau
c'est classe
ça c'est la vie
tu sens oui miracle après miracle il a
réussi à survivre il faut que je te
parle de quelque chose
jusqu'à toi t on
il est perdu
même les plus petites choses ont une
signification
je
[Applaudissements]
qui est prudemment
j'ai passé que tout est capable c'est
définitif non
possible que parfois du mauvais
pour vous que dupont
[Musique]
alors c'est ma faute si elle est morte
je leur ai rendu
je le jure
[Musique]